from child stars to Legendary dads these
sitcom personalities made the world a
brighter place before their tragic
passings
from 1976 to 1985 audiences enjoyed the
Antics happening in Mel's Diner on Alice
a sitcom based on the 1974 Martin
Scorsese film Alice doesn't live here
anymore for the pilot episode of Alice
Alfred lutter who played the titular
Widow son in the film reprized the role
of Tommy Hyatt but for each of its
subsequent episodes Philip McKeon played
the young Tommy Mickey and started his
career as a child model and scored the
spot on Alice when the show's lead Linda
Lavin saw him in a Broadway performance
of Medea and Jason and recommended him
for the role after Mel's Diner finally
closed its doors mckeon's acting work
was sparse he worked on the other side
of the camera starting in the early 90s
producing 1995's Murder in the First in
2005's the jacket among others
a few years before his death McKeon
moved to Wimberley Texas to be closer to
his family and host his own Talk Radio
Show in December 2019 McCann died from a
long illness at the age of 55. Yvette
Wilson began her career as a stand-up
comic and she also made audiences laugh
on the big screen in 1994's House Party
3 and 1995's Friday but she was best
known for her role in upn's Moesha when
the teenage characters needed a place to
hang out they went to the den owned by
Wilson's character Andel Wilkerson the
actress went on to reprise the role of
Andel on the spin-off The Parkers
unfortunately Wilson lost her battle
with multiple illnesses in June 2012 at
the age of 48.
on the give forward page Wilson's friend
Jeffrey pittle created to help cover her
medical costs pittle wrote that Wilson
was being told by doctors that her
cervical cancer which had been an
extended retreat was coming back more
aggressive than ever at the same time
she'd already been struggling with
kidney disease having endured kidney
transplant surgery and dialysis
treatments
just like I was when I was your age
savvy Savvy gorgeous
Lamont Bentley played neighbor friend
and occasional love interest Hakeem on
Moesha and its spin-off The Parkers
before those series he was Crazy K in
1995's Tales from the Hood an aspiring
rapper as well as an actor Bentley took
on the role of Tupac Shakur for the 2001
TV movie too legit the MC Hammer story
and that same year he appeared with Dr
Dre and Snoop Dogg in the wash some of
his earliest work was also in the
short-lived but critically acclaimed Fox
series South Central
in January 2005 Bentley was on his way
home from the screening of the short
film shards when he got into a single
car accident he reportedly lost control
of his vehicle while heading toward a
freeway off-ramp after the car plowed
through a fence and rolled down an
embankment he was thrown from the car
and into traffic where he was hit by
five other vehicles
shortly afterward he died from his
injuries he was 31 years old the
original Saved by the Bell wouldn't have
been the same without Samuel's Screech
Powers a lovable nerd played by Dustin
Diamond although he took on other small
parts throughout his career Screech
remained Diamond's most famous character
I will be your Yoda
and I will be your everything
the actors starred in this role across
the original series's Four Seasons and
reprized it and Saved By The Bell the
College Years Diamond again played
Screech as principal belding's assistant
in Saved by the Bell the new class
furthermore he appeared in two TV movies
based on the popular franchise
sadly Diamond died in 2021 when he was
only 44 years old many of his former
co-stars paid tribute to him on social
media including Mario Lopez who posted a
photo of himself and the late actor on
Instagram and expressed his sadness
about Diamond's death
according to an article by the
University of Colorado Cancer Center the
actors untimely death came just a few
weeks after receiving a cancer diagnosis
the report further explains that his
official cause of death stage 4 small
cell carcinoma can spread rapidly before
causing noticeable pain which is a
significant factor in why he died so
quickly after diagnosis
Family Matters character Steve Urkel
found himself in the arms of a jealous
woman when he started dating Myra
monkhouse played by Michelle Thomas
Myra's possessive nature proved too hard
for Steve to handle but fans still love
Thomas's hilarious portrayal of this
over-enthusiastic young woman
Thomas starred in this recurring role
for 55 episodes and is among the most
memorable Side characters of the hit
series
before Family Matters Thomas also
appeared in The Cosby Show and she later
starred as Cali Rogers in The Young and
the Restless
sadly the young actress's career ended
just as it was getting started in 1998
the New York Times reported that Thomas
died of cancer at the age of 30. the
actress was diagnosed with
intra-abdominal desmoplastic small round
cell tumor in 1997 and died after
attempts at treatment proved fruitless
co-stars still remember Thomas fondly
many of her former castmates
commemorated her 51st birthday by
gathering to share their memories of the
actress speaking warmly of her talent
and kind nature Will and Grace made
audiences laugh for 11 Seasons with a
nearly 10-year gap between Seasons 8 and
9. of all the many Side characters in
the series socialite Leslie Jordan's
Beverly Leslie has some of the most
hilarious lines this staunch
conservative regularly exchanges Snappy
insults with Karen Walker instills the
show whenever he appears on screen
besides appearing on Will and Grace
actor Leslie Jordan left his mark on
dozens of television shows and movies
and demonstrated a unique talent for
making audiences laugh
as CBS News reported in January 2023
paramedics unsuccessfully tried to
revive Jordan after he was found
unresponsive in his car following an
accident according to the report the
actor had arterioscleratic
cardiovascular disease which caused a
sudden cardiac dysfunction that led to
his death although there was some
question as to whether the accident
caused his death an autopsy revealed
that his official cause of death was
indeed cardiac dysfunction
Jordan was 67 when he died and was an
avid Instagram user fittingly many of
the comedians as fans took to his
platform of choice to bid him a fond
farewell although the 2023 Night Court
Revival is undeniably funny the original
1984 sitcom is still a classic in its
own right Marky post starred as
Christine Sullivan for eight seasons of
the series leaving a hilarious
impression on fans
post also appeared in other sitcoms and
dramas including cameos in The Love Boat
and scrubs additionally film audiences
likely remember her as Mary's mom from
the 1998 movie There's Something About
Mary in 2021 a rolling stone article
explained that the actress died of
cancer at age 70. the article highlights
tributes from several of post's former
castmates including a touching tweet
from Night Court alumni John B larriket
however as deadline reports posts
remained dedicated to her craft even
after her cancer diagnosis taking on
several acting projects while seeking
chemotherapy treatments
Fred Willard spent decades making
audiences laugh as offbeat characters
and a large body of work in the film
World Willard starred alongside comedy
Legends in films like Anchorman the
Legend of Ron Burgundy and best in Xiao
however some of his most memorable roles
found him in the world of sitcoms where
he often played quirky father figures
for example Everybody Loves Raymond fans
likely remember him as Hank McDougall
Amy's eternally funny father of course
Willard's recurring role as Frank Dunphy
on Modern Family is also a standout his
good-natured playful personality
perfectly fit Willard who played this
role in 14 episodes of the award-winning
Series in May 2020 Willard's daughter
hope announced on Twitter the actor had
passed away peacefully after suffering
cardiac arrest
fans and Friends alike responded to the
Tweet expressing their sadness at the
loss of such a long-standing actor we
didn't have to write him jokes
whatever we wrote when he said it be
twice as funny
in the late 1980s Alan Thicke became a
fan favorite sitcom father on Growing
Pains his character Dr Jason Seaver is a
psychiatrist who trades his Hospital job
for a life as a stay-at-home dad
the series was heartwarming and
hilarious with thick at the helm in
addition to his time as Dr Seaver the
actor appeared in over 100 different
film and television projects including
cameos and other sitcoms dramas and even
some Animated Series in December 2016
USA Today reported that Thicke died of a
rare cardiac condition with symptoms
similar to her heart attack
thick suffered a ruptured aorta which
can be fatal without immediate medical
attention sadly as an article from HCA
Healthcare today explains thick died
just three hours after collapsing at a
hockey rink indicating that the
condition was not treated in time after
his death friends and fans posted
condolences on social media including
Canadian Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
who tweeted about Thick's Canadian Pride
after achieving success as half of the
hip-hop Duo DJ Jazzy Jeff and The Fresh
Prince Will Smith eventually bridged the
worlds of rap and TV with the Fresh
Prince of Bel Air in the show Smith
played a fictionalized version of
himself who's sent to live with his aunt
and uncle in Bel Air after a
confrontation with the violent gang over
the course of the series James Avery
would become one of the most well-loved
father figures on American television as
he portrayed Smith's Uncle Phil along
with his role in Fresh Prince Avery was
known for his exceptional Voice work he
was the voice of the villain Shredder in
the original Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles animated series and of James
Rhodes AKA War Machine in the 90s Iron
Man cartoon most of his live-action
roles were of the smaller variety and in
a 2007 interview with the New York Film
Academy he was candid about missing the
spotlight saying you can either be a
movie star or an actor I'm an actor but
I've done pretty good
Avery died in December 2013 due to
complications from open heart surgery he
was 68.
[Music]